we welcome you back to CBS mornings we
are hearing renewed calls across the
country for change after the release of
The Tyree Nichols video it shows a 29
year old father being beaten repeatedly
for three minutes by Memphis police
officers following a traffic stop
earlier this month now he died three
days later civil rights attorney Ben
Crump represents Tyree Nichols family
and he joins us now good morning Ben
I've seen many interviews good morning
I've seen it's not really a good morning
I've been thinking about this story all
weekend ever since I saw the video I've
seen many interviews with the Nichols
family over the weekend so I know
they're not doing well but I know you're
in constant contact with him can you
just tell us how they're getting through
you know Gail as his mother Revan Wells
said
she believes uh God sent her son Tyree
Nichols here on an assignment and now
he's going back home to be with his
heavenly father and she has to believe
that because that's the only thing that
can allow her to cope with this tragic
death of her son and she believes Gail
there has to be something good that
comes from this tragedy
yeah I think we're all trying to think
what is the Silver Lining here because
right now it's very difficult to see I
think when many people saw the
identities of these officers and that
they were all black I think that was
very painful and very surprising to many
in the black community does that make a
difference to you does that make this
case different to you
well this case is uh important on so
many levels Gail King and as I have said
in my 25 years of doing this civil
rights work all across America and you
and I have talked about many of these
tragedies it is not the race of the
police officer that is the determining
factor of whether they're going to
engage in the use of excessive force it
is the race of the citizens and
oftentimes it's black and brown citizens
that bear the brunt of the brutality we
don't see videos Gail King of our white
brothers and sisters who are unarmed
having this kind of excessive force
exerted against them
uh Ben it's Vlad I in the video we see
other additional First Responders just
standing around I think that's what
disturbs a lot of people it's not just
these officers it's other First
Responders on their scene who aren't
doing anything to help this young man on
the ground what should happen to them
well they should be accountable as well
uh the fire
D while they investigating I don't know
how much we have to investigate because
you see Tyree Nichols clearly after he's
been plummeted I mean he's been kicked
he's been pushed he's been hit with
police sticks and he's there handcuffs
moaning on the ground and everybody's
walking around non-ship not like like
his business as usual so it should be
accountability for everybody on the
video and I want to be exceedingly clear
on this point the fact that these five
black police officers were terminated
arrested and charged within 20 days uh
from this tragedy
is now the blueprint going forward I
mean you you can't tell us anymore that
it takes six months or it takes a year
kind of like Eric Garner when he was
killed on video or whether it's EJ
Bradford shot in the Thanksgiving in
Alabama on video uh the police chief
said it was important that they the
community saw Swift action and that they
moved swiftly to Justice and so he in
our community say when white police
officers kill us too then we want to say
it's important to the community also to
secure fashion and Swift Justice this is
the blueprint now going forward
uh Ben it's Tony uh you know these five
officers were part of an anti-crime unit
that had a mission of restoring peace to
communities they were in Memphis that
were struggling with reckless driving
with a rise in violent crime with murder
what needs to be done looking at the
bigger picture to make sure that police
can't do their jobs communities can feel
safe without having cases like this
continue to come up how do you strike a
balance that benefits all parties here
well Tony as we told President Biden
when uh we were talking to him
that we have to use this tragic video
and it's a a very hard video because you
think about the Rodney King video in
1992 and that's what it reminds many
people of or they say it's far worse and
these were watershed moments in America
the 1992 Rodney King video and now the
2023 video from Tyree Nichols killing by
the police and so we the past George
Floyd Justice and police said that
Congress has to re-engage we haven't
seen Ben let's see Ben if it is a
watershed moment but I'm trying to
figure out how it even got to this point
even the police chief in Memphis seems
to be questioning whether it was a
legitimate traffic stop what can you
tell us about how it went so wrong so
quickly and so violently
well we believe the Scorpion unit uh
this organized crime unit commonly
referred to in cities as the jump out
boys that many in the white Community
have never heard of but in the black
community and brown Community it's these
police officers that jump out all of a
sudden they swarm you and they're very
aggressive and they normally are are
trampling on your constitutional rights
and you see it in Tyrese video where
they start cursing at him and being so
aggressive from the very beginning that
Tyree said what did I do that's what I'm
trying to figure out what was the crime
that he committed or they thought he
committed
but we're going to have a press
conference tomorrow with another citizen
who said he was just going to get a
pizza about three or four days before
this happened to Tyree Nichols and that
they attacked him threw him on the
ground put a gun to his head and he
reported it uh the next day called twice
and they never responded and the belief
Gail and Tony and Brad is if they would
have just responded then maybe just
maybe Tyree Nichols would not have been
killed three days later
yeah Mr crumpy always bring passion of
these stories these cases we wish there
weren't so many of them but we know we
will see you again soon we'll keep
talking about this subject Ben Crump
thank you very much thank you this is
CBS mornings we'll be right back